make more money in nineteen days think
you're too busy for another project
whether busy or not ask yourself do I
have the right balance of joy money and
flow in my life if you want to now come
different from the one your current path
is leading to somehow you'll have to
find the time being too busy maybe the
new social currency but the real winner
is fine time to do what matters to them
when you're launching your first side
hustle it can be tricky to figure out
how to start here's a suggested timeline
to get you going by spending one hour a
day for 19 days you'll be off the ground
before months has gone by day one first
things first
decide what your side hustle will be
what skills will you utilize what
passion will you tap into what problem
will you saw day - what's a deliverable
make a decision will just be a product
or service of some kind of hybrid how
will you make money off your side hustle
d3 think about the ideal customers or
clients for this idea who are they and
what are their struggles if you have
five customers or clients
what would they all have in common they
four set a budget determine all costs
necessary and keep them as low as
possible stay 5 write down 3 key
benefits for your new psychotics this is
particularly important because the
benefits you offer matter much more than
any other details or features stay 6
decide how much you'll charge for your
office stay 7 set up a simple one-page
website you'll need to make a
complicated or fancy or foot guide on
how to get a website in less than an
hour visit born for this book calm they
8 write a simple sales page free website
again it doesn't need to be complicated
just think about what you're offering
and how it will help people oh and tell
them what they need to do the purchaser
sign up write the frequently asked
questions section for your website
think about what questions you would
have upon encountering your offer for
the first time what would you want to
know day 10 add a PayPal button or other
checkout process to your one-page
website remember if you don't have a way
to get paid it's called a hobby not
business day 11 alternatively offer the
invoice clients for your service if you
choose this option make sure there's a
clear way for them to commit the
payments before you do a bunch of work
for them day 12 show your draft project
as three people and ask for feedback
for best results don't just ask friends
ask people who fit the background a
profile you identified on day three
after their unfiltered opinion and make
sure they tell you anything that isn't
immediately clear to them day 13 launch
publisher offer a simple website
congratulations
but don't celebrate too much because
it's more to be done day 14
tell your friends let them know what
you're working on and how they can help
spread the word day 15
hello the people you know friends of
friends colleagues former classmates
don't try to sell them directly just ask
them to refer your project on if they
know anyone who might be a good fit for
it
day 16 mention your offering and social
media again don't try too hard to sell
but do show people what you've made day
17 ask your first customer or client to
share his or her honest opinion what
does that person like and how could you
improve day 18 launch again think what
you've learned thus far and identify a
few specific weeks does the price need
to change do you need more information
on the sales page relaunch with your new
office day 19 just as retail stores
frame the first solidarity' find a way
to celebrate the beginning of your side
hustle by commemorating the first check
you cache the email notification of your
first customer or something else the
point is they join in your success and
better yet and knowing that the best is
yet to come
you
you